Professor Mark Saltzman:
Welcome,
so we're going to continue
today talking about drug
delivery.
I want to pick up where I
started last time,
where at the end of the class I
was trying to convince you that
one way to think about drug
delivery was to take what we
know is a complex system,
the human body,
and represent in a simple way.
This is a common approach to
engineering, where you take a
system that might be a complex
system and you say,
'How could I represent it in
the most simple way?'
Then you ask the question,
'What comes out that simple
description and does it fit
experimental evidence,
does it match what we know
about how things work?'
This simplification was to
take the human body and
represent it as a simple stirred
vessel of water and to ask the
question,
'If we introduce drugs into the
body do they behave in the same
was as if I introduced drugs
into this well-stirred vessel
full of water,
are there things that match
about it?'
We made the vessel a little bit
more complicated than a simple
tank full of water in that we
allow its volume to be variable.
This is going to account for
the fact that when we introduce
drugs into the body,
some of them are going to go to
different compartments within
the body.
Some will remain confined to
the blood plasma space,
for example,
while some will be distributed
more widely.
So, we'll adjust the volume of
the vessel to match the drug
some way and how it's
distributed.
And we'll assume that it's a
magical vessel in another sense,
and that drugs disappear and
they disappear in a very orderly
fashion.
That is they--the rate of
disappearance of the drugs is
equal to some constant times the
concentration.
It's a first-order rate of
elimination from this
compartment.
If we do that,
I wrote on the board today the
equations that are in the box at
the end of the chapter,
in Chapter 14.
Just to review them very
quickly, that if we have a
system like this we know that
mass has to be conserved.
One way to write down the
conservation of mass equation is
like this.
The amount that comes in minus
the amount that goes out,
plus any molecules that are
generated inside,
minus any molecules that are
consumed inside the system has
to be equal to accumulation.
IN--OUT + GEN--CONS =
ACCAccumulation is just the
rate of change of concentration.
If molecules are accumulating
inside the vessel that means
their concentration is either
going up or down,
and so accumulation is the rate
of change with time of the total
number of molecules inside the
vessel: -kM = dM/dt.
If we went through this
analysis for the system that I
drew up here,
and the particular
circumstance,
that I'm going to inject drugs
into the body or into this
vessel at time t = 0.
After time t = 0,
no molecules are going to be
introduced.
This is when I'm just giving
all the drug at once at the
beginning, so I'm simulating an
intravenous injection.
There's nothing coming in and
there's going out over the--in
terms of drugs introduced over
the time that I'm interested in.
No molecules of drug are being
generated inside the body but
they are being consumed,
they are disappearing in some
way.
They're disappearing by this
first-order process where the
rate of disappearance is equal
to a constant times the number
of molecules that are still
available (-kM).
I could solve this
equation, this differential
equation--I've told you if you
don't know about solving
differential equations,
don't worry.
Another way to think about it
is here's the solution,
you could convince yourself
that this solution does match
this equation,
'If I take the derivative of
this and plug it back in here do
I get the right answer?'
That's another way to think
about or you could just trust me
that it is the right solution to
the equation.
We also have to know one more
thing, how many molecules of
drug we introduced at the
beginning,
and we're going to call that
number M_0 and
so the final result is M =
M_0</i
>*e^(-kt).
The amount of drug that I have
within the body at any time is
equal to the amount I had at
time 0,
times e^(-kt),
where k is this rate
constant.
So, if I knew what the rate
constant was,
I knew how long after the
injection,
I knew how many molecules I'd
injected at the beginning,
I could calculate how many I
have at any time.
Another way to write this
is to write not in terms of the
total number of molecules in the
body but in terms of the
concentration.
To get concentration,
I just divide both sides by the
volume.
So, concentration in the body's
function of time is equal to
this expression.
I've plotted that for you last
time and that plot's shown here.
If I looked on a simple plot of
concentration versus time,
concentration starts at a
maximum and it drops,
and it drops exponentially over
time.
Turns out this very simple
model matches very well the way
many drugs behave if you inject
them into the body.
If you inject them
intravenously,
in this case,
in that the concentration
immediately after the injection
will be the highest and
concentration will drop over
time.
For many drugs the way that
they're eliminated from the body
does result in first-order
elimination like this,
so you see this pattern.
Now, another useful
parameter to describe here is
that--is what's called the
half-life.
How long do drugs remain in the
body, what's the time course of
that.
The half-life is defined as the
time that it takes for drug
concentration to drop from one
value to half of that value.
It might drop from C =
C_0 down to
瘠_0,
it might drop from
瘠_0 down to a
劍_0,
from a 1/4 to an 1/8th.
It doesn't matter where you
start at, for processes where
you have first-order elimination
the time to get rid of half of
the drugs that are remaining is
always the same.
That's a characteristic of
first-order processes.
That half-life is just equal to
ln(2/k).
What this plot over here shows
you is how rapidly would drugs
disappear for drugs that had
different half-lives or
different rates of elimination?
It's plotted on a semi-log plot
so this is the natural--this is
the log_10 actually of
drug concentration in the body
as a function of time.
Here's a drug that has a
half-life of 600 minutes;
long half-life means it stays
in the body for a long time you
clear it--you get rid of it very
slowly.
A shorter half-life you get rid
of more quickly;
a very short half-life you get
rid of very quickly.
What's the result of that?
That for drugs with a short
half-life, drugs that the body
gets rid of more rapidly,
if the desired effect isn't
achieved with one dose I have to
give another dose.
I'd have to give another dose
if the drug had a half-life of
six minutes, I'd have to give
another dose when the drug
concentration dropped down to a
very low level if I want to
maintain a high concentration.
Knowing the half-life is really
important and when you--we'll
see in a minute here how this
same factor is important for
drugs,
not just that are intravenously
injected but for drugs that are
taken by pills as well.
This is something that if
you're making a drug,
or you're making it to sell,
you need to know about because
you need to tell people how
frequently they can take the
drug.
That depends on how quickly
your body gets rid of it.
That'll be more clear in just a
moment, I hope.
That's the simplest,
possible model,
and it matches very well the
behavior of many drugs when
they're injected intravenously.
How could I extend this to talk
about--to think about other
situations as well?
Well, what's different if I
don't directly inject the
molecules into the body but I
take them by a pill?
That means if this is most of
your body, now when I take a
pill I'm not introducing the
drugs all at once,
but I'm putting them into my
intestinal system and they're
being slowly absorbed into the
body.
One way to describe that is
to add another compartment to
the model.
To add another compartment to
this simple model and say,
here is a dose,
but it's a dose in form of a
pill.
The patient's going to swallow
it and then that drug will be
available in a particular
sub-compartment of the body.
Now, it's going to be in the
intestine and it will be
absorbed from the intestine into
the bulk of the body,
into the circulatory system
where it can distribute.
Now, I'm not going to write
down the equations for this but
you could do that,
and you could solve this
equation.
What you would find is this
curve here which matches your
intuition, probably.
That what happens if I swallow
a pill and that pill dissolves
in my intestinal tract and then
molecules get absorbed slowly
into the body,
is that right after I take the
pill the concentration hasn't
changed inside my blood yet,
inside the bulk of my body.
The molecules are still
outside your body,
they're still in your
intestinal tract.
They slowly get absorbed and as
they absorbed concentration
rises, you can see concentration
rising here.
Now, what happens to those
molecules that are circulating
in your body?
Well, the same thing happens to
them as what would happen to
them if they were injected,
is that your body's trying to
get rid of them.
At this point here,
the rate at which they're being
absorbed is much faster than the
rate that your body is getting
rid of them,
and so the concentration is
rising.
It eventually reaches a peak,
most of the drug has now been
absorbed and concentrations
start to fall.
What's happening during this
phase is that most of the drug
has now been absorbed so the
rate at which you're
getting--it's coming into your
body from the pill that's
dissolving and the molecules
being absorbed through the
intestinal tract is being--that
rate is less than the rate at
which your body is getting rid
of it,
and so the concentration starts
to drop.
If you took Acetaminophen
or if you took Ibuprofen,
which is Advil or Motrin,
what's happening in your body
is that over some period of
time, usually ten minutes to
half an hour,
the molecules are being
absorbed from your intestine;
the concentration in your blood
is starting to rise.
If you took a pill and then you
measured concentrations in your
blood, you'd see those
concentrations start to rise.
They reach a peak,
say half an hour after you take
it, and hopefully whatever aches
or pains,
or whatever the reason you're
taking the medication for,
you start to feel an effect of
it after some of period of time
and then concentrations start to
fall.
Now, eventually they'll
fall to such a low level that
the drug doesn't have its
desired effect anymore.
In the event that your pain
hasn't gone away you'll take
another dose,
in which case the same events
will repeat;
drug will be absorbed,
concentration will go up and
then it'll start to fall again.
What you would see on repeated
doses, here I show the effect of
getting one dose at time 0,
giving another dose at 120
minutes, giving a third dose at
240 minutes, so this would be
taking a drug--taking pills
every two hours.
Each one of the pills you take
yields the same behavior.
The total concentration in your
blood is just the sum of each of
those--the effect of each those
doses.
Each of those doses would have
produced what are the dotted
lines here;
the total effect that you would
see is this purple line.
Let's say this drug is
effective when the concentration
is 0.1.
Well, that means after 20
minutes or so,
after the first dose,
I get a level that's above 0.1
and I start to feel some relief
from the symptoms.
Concentrations peak,
I'm feeling good,
they start to drop.
I know because I read the
bottle, it said take a dose
every two hours.
I take another dose at two
hours, the concentration rises
again.
So, by repeating these doses
every two hours I maintain the
concentration over 0.1 and I
have an effect from the drug
that lasts a long time.
What if at 0.3,
what if at a concentration of
0.3 you begin to see side
effects?
What if at a concentration 0.3
you begin to see side effects?
Well, no problem after the
first dose, after the second
dose I've slipped into the range
where I might start to see side
effects.
After the third dose I'm
clearly up into the range where
side effects might happen.
So your--there's some danger as
you repeat doses that because
drug is accumulating that you
could slip into a range where
you start to see side effects.
Now, the reason why you
can--I mentioned this last time
but it should be more clear now
when you look at this picture,
the reason why you can take
some drugs like Ibuprofen or
aspirin, or drugs that you
typically buy over the counter
without a doctor's prescription,
and therefore without a
doctor's guidance on taking
them.
The reason why you can buy
those and use them yourself is
because toxic levels don't occur
until high on this chart;
side effects don't occur until
high on this chart.
You can safely take it and
without much risk that side
effects are going to occur.
For many drugs,
however, the side effects occur
at lower concentrations.
Concentrations that are closer
to the dose you need in order to
have a useful response.
Those are ones that you have to
be more careful with;
those are ones that physicians
don't want to prescribe unless
they're seeing you frequently
enough that they can monitor how
well you're doing with the drug.
This should give you some idea
about why that happens.
People have been thinking
for a long time,
we've talked about why
different modes of
administration.
Oral administration is the
preferred mode for almost all
kinds of drugs because it can be
self-administered,
it's very convenient and people
don't mind taking drugs that
way.
But there are problems with it,
for example,
this problem of how do you
maintain constant levels within
this safe range over long
periods of time.
This just shows that same plot
again, with the levels rising
and falling, with the minimum
effective and the maximum
tolerated concentrations shown
explicitly here.
What's shown by the blue line
is sort of what you might
prefer, some kind of a drug
delivery system that gives you
long lasting concentrations but
concentrations that don't rise
and fall in the way that they do
when you're taking individual
doses repeatedly.
Now, could you do this with
an oral--with a pill?
Could you achieve this sort of
long lasting constant
concentration with a pill?
Well, you could in some rare
circumstances,
right?
Think about--how would that
happen?
Well, maybe a drug has a very
long half-life.
If you could design a drug that
had a very, very long half-life
you could maintain
concentrations for a long time.
Nate do you have a
question?Student:
Aren't there now these time
release
capsules?Professor Mark
Saltzman: Yes,
so let me get to that in just a
minute, but that's a really good
point.
An alternate to that would be
what if I had a drug that had a
long half-life,
well that would naturally have
this kind of a pattern.
Instead of that,
what if I design a pill that
releases it slowly?
Thinking back a couple slides
ago what if I designed a pill
that was absorbed very slowly
from the intestine?
If I make it absorb so slowly
that drug is continually coming
into your body over a long
period of time.
The peak in this diagram occurs
after only 30 minutes or so.
What if I designed a pill such
that the drug was absorbed over
five hours?
Then I could extend this period
here and I could have drug
concentrations that remain long
a long time,
this would be five hours
instead of 60 minutes down here
where the peak occurs.
What's the limit of that?
Why is there a limit on how far
you can go with that approach?
Justin?Student:
There's only so much
drug.Professor Mark
Saltzman: There's only so
much drug,
so it might be that if you do
that then your pill is getting
larger and larger presumably.
There's only so big a pill you
could swallow,
so that could be a problem.
Most compounds fairly potent,
if you had something that was
potent you could still put
several days worth into a pill
that was of a reasonable size.
That might not be the
limitation for every drug but
that's a really good point.
What's another limitation?
Yeah Ilya?Student:
Safety, I think that if put a
[inaudible].Professor
Mark Saltzman: So that's a
real--safety is a really good
point.
What I've been talking about
here is how these things behave
in an average person.
What if you happen to absorb
drug much more quickly than the
average person?
You've got several days worth
of drug you're taking in one
pill but it gets absorbed more
quickly,
you go into this toxic or side
effect range,
so safety is certainly an
issue.
One more, how often do you eat?
Why?
Why don't we only eat once a
day?
Student: [inaudible]
Professor Mark
Saltzman:
Sorry?Student:
The breakdown of food
[inaudible].Professor
Mark Saltzman: Because
that's the rate at which you
absorbed foot and that's the
rate at which your intestinal
system works.
Things pass through at a
certain rate.
You can't really slow that
down, you can't really--you can
eat more and feel full for a
period of time,
feel satisfied but you can--you
won't continue to be absorbing
more drugs because whatever you
take into your intestine passes
through in a matter of hours.
There is a transit rate through
your intestinal system that is
not very changeable.
A pill that you take is only
going to be there as long as
it's still in your intestinal
tract and there's a limit to how
long it will last.
It's not going to last forever.
We know this from our
experience with food and
eliminating the waste products
of food,
that there's a time course
there that can't be altered very
much.
There's a limit to how much you
can do in terms of sustaining or
prolonging release with an oral
system so people have designed
other methods.
As I mentioned,
this is my research lab,
this is my specialty so I'm
going to talk about some things
that we've designed to try to
get around these barriers for
certain kinds of drugs and
certain situations.
One way that you could get
around it is by designing,
not something that's taken
orally, but by designing a
delivery system that's
implanted.
Now, when you start thinking
about 'this is not a pill but an
implant', you're automatically
limiting it to certain kinds of
conditions.
You wouldn't want to get an
implant for a headache or
something that you know is going
to go away.
You're talking about serious
medical problems that are
ongoing.
This might be for something
like treating diabetes where you
need to take drugs everyday,
multiple times a day.
It might be for treating
something like cancer where a
course of chemotherapy could
last for several weeks or
several months.
It might be for treating long
term disorders like hemophilia
where you're deficient in factor
8,
a protein in the blood and you
need to have injections of
factor 8 continuously.
So, it's only for certain kinds
of things but you could imagine
that there are those kinds of
medical problems that you could
treat.
Well, here's one way to
achieve long release of drug
into the body from an implant.
To make implants out of
biocompatible materials like
polymers.
What's shown on the bottom of
this slide here is an implant
that's made of a gray substance,
which is a polymer,
a biocompatible polymer.
Imagine it's something like the
contact lenses that you would
put in contact with your eye.
These are materials that are
synthetic materials but
they're--your body doesn't
respond to them as foreign
objects very strongly.
You can put some polymers in
contact with one of the most
sensitive areas of your body,
your eye, and it can remain
there for a long period of time
without very much response of
your body to the material.
Well, what if you took that
material embedded within it drug
molecules?
That's what's shown here.
In fact, it's not just
molecules of drug,
its solid particles of drug
which are shown as the orange
dots here,
so that this whole thing is
maybe the size of a coin,
maybe the size of a dime.
What I'm showing you here is a
cross-section of that dime,
dime laying flat,
I cut it like this,
you're looking at it from the
side.
It's a millimeter or so in
depth;
several millimeters in diameter.
It's a solid polymer,
but inside of it are particles
of the drug that you want to
deliver.
What these graphs show are
experiments that we did - this
was back in the late 1980s,
where we put drug molecules
into these polymers and then
just dropped them into a test
tube and ask the question,
'Could we release drugs slowly
from these implants so we could
make a long lasting pill
essentially,
make a long lasting implant
that slowly released drugs?'
This shows for a drug that
is used to treat Parkinson's
disease, another sort of chronic
indication,
where patients have to take
drugs everyday for the rest of
their life.
This shows that when you drop
these implants into a test tube
full of water,
the Dopamine is released and
it's released for a fairly long
period of time.
This is days here,
so this point here is 30 days,
about a month.
One of these systems released a
drug for a period of a month.
One released for almost three
months here, a sort of
continuous and reliable source
of drug,
so you can make implants that
release drug molecules over long
periods of time.
The rest of these curves
just show you that you could do
this with drugs like Dopamine
that are small in molecular
weight and water soluble.
You could do it with proteins,
which are higher in molecular
weight, and also water soluble.
You could even do it with gene
therapy vectors,
with plasmids we talked about
several weeks ago.
Plasmid DNA,
these are big molecules;
very difficult to administer.
We talked about how hard it is
to get plasmid DNA inside of
cells, but you can put them into
these polymers and they'll
slowly be released from the
polymer over a long period of
time.
So, one could potentially make
a long lasting gene therapy
deliver system.
One of the advantages of
making these materials out of
polymers is that we now know how
to--you can make all kinds of
things out of polymers.
That's one of the nice features
of plastics or polymers,
is that you can mold them and
shape them into all sorts of
kinds of devices.
Here, this is that same kind of
material, but instead of making
a coin out of it,
we coated it onto the surface
of a wire.
This is a bare wire,
and it's the kind of wire that
you can put into the brain and
you can measure recordings of
what's happening in the brain
extracellular space.
You can measure action
potentials and electrical
activity in the brain by putting
electrodes in.
Physicians do this all the time
to measure activity in the brain
in patients that have epilepsy,
for example.
One of the problems with
these materials is that when you
put them into the brain they're
not completely biocompatible.
The brain does respond to them.
It will form a scar around them
and eventually the electrode
won't work anymore.
We coated these electrodes with
a polymer that contained drug.
In this case it's a drug,
dexamethasone.
It's a steroid that prevents
scar formation locally.
So, you make a wire that's able
to record, but it's also able to
deliver a drug.
Now, when this is placed in the
brain you not only can make the
recordings, but the drug is
slowly being released and it
prevents scar formation around
the outside of the electrode,
and the electrode will function
for a longer period of time
inside the patient.
This is an example of
taking a medical device,
the kind of devices we've been
talking about,
and will continue to talk
about, and making it safer and
better by adding drug delivery.
The other advantage to this is
that I didn't have to deliver
steroids all over the body in
order to accomplish this effect.
We put the steroids right on
the device and they act locally
when they're needed.
You don't have steroids
delivered all over the body but
only at the site where you're
doing the intervention.
Well, this has become a very
big business in--around the
world, and that's because
several companies took this kind
of technology that had been
developed and used it in a very
clinically important
application.
What this shows you here is
a stent, it's made of a metal.
This is one kind of it,
there are many sort of versions
of this.
Imagine this is a stent that's
expanded over this tube that's
inside.
You can imagine this design
here which looks like a--kind of
chicken wire fence could be
collapsed because the wires
are--would bend and you could
collapse this into a smaller
form.
What they do is they collapse
this into a form around the end
of a tube called a catheter.
A shrunken version of this
stent, shrunken only in its
diameter being reduced,
is then put into your body.
The catheter is a long narrow
plastic tube that can be
inserted into a distal artery
like your femoral artery in your
leg.
Physicians know how to move
this catheter up into your body
and actually into the blood
vessels of your heart.
They put this tube up into your
coronary artery.
One of the manifestations
of heart disease is that
coronary arteries become
sclerotic,
they become narrowed because
you get atherosclerotic plaques
there.
If the vessel becomes narrow
then blood can't flow through
very easily.
That can lead to pain in your
chest because your heart is not
getting enough blood and can
lead to a heart attack,
or loss of blood flow to the
heart and death of that tissue.
When that process starts to
happen, what if you put one of
these catheters in?
I didn't tell you that the
catheter also has a balloon on
the tip and the balloon is
underneath this stent.
So, once you've got it in
place, you blow up the balloon,
the stent becomes larger,
it forces the blood vessel to
become open.
Then you deflate the balloon,
and because this is made of
metal it doesn't deflate when
the balloon deflates.
It stays there inside your
blood vessel,
holding the blood vessel open
so now blood flow can continue.
This is a very common
medical therapy that's done as
an alternative to heart bypass.
We'll talk about heart bypass
operations in a few weeks.
Instead of having a new blood
vessel put into your heart,
which is a major operation,
you can put this stent in,
blow up the balloon,
inflate the vessel,
and the stent is left behind in
order to keep the vessel open.
Well you could imagine that
this is not a normal
circumstance.
Your blood vessels were not
designed to have a piece of
metal inserted in them to hold
them open.
In fact, they respond to this.
They respond in the way that
your body responds to having
foreign objects put into it,
it tries to form a scar around
it.
Often that scar formation will
occur so aggressively that scar
tissue starts to fill in the
vessel where--that you've
opened,
and this process is called
restenosis.
What these companies did
was took these stents,
which were known to be very
effective,
and physicians are very capable
and able to put these into the
body, into the coronary vascular
system now readily.
They coated the wires with a
polymer and that's what's shown
in this cartoon here.
The yellow is a wire and this
gray is a polymer like the
polymers I've been describing,
and why coat it with a polymer?
Because now you can put drugs
inside the polymer and the drugs
will be slowly released from
this polymer coating.
This becomes not just a stent,
but what they call in the
industry a drug-eluting stent.
It releases drugs that prevent
scar formation locally.
A patient that has heart
disease gets one of these stents
put in their vascular system,
they open up the artery,
and now that stent not only
holds the artery open but it
contains enough drug molecules
that are released slowly over
time that prevents this
restenosis and the vessel stays
open for,
hopefully, the rest of their
life.
We're going to talk more
about stents and mechanical
objects like this that are used
for medical therapy later.
The important part here is the
coating on the stent which
releases drugs very slowly.
It's really just an extension
of what I showed you in the last
couple of slides.
These were released into
the--approved by the FDA in 2002
or so, a few years ago,
and became one of the biggest
selling drug products ever in
U.S.
history, which tells you
something about sort of the
clinical need for things like
this.
Again, like that other system,
one of the advantages is you're
not delivering drugs over the
whole body but only in the
vessel where you need it,
only in the vessel where the
scar is going to form.
You can deliver drugs locally,
you can prevent side effects
that would happen in other
places.
One more example,
and in that example I just
showed you, that you have a
stent which is going to remain
in the patient for a long period
of time.
There's a good reason to put
the stent there,
to hold this vessel open so
that you can get good blood
flow.
In other situations you might
want to introduce an implant but
you don't want the implant to
last forever.
Because it's not a natural
material, you might like the
implant to go away.
There are some polymers like
this that can be made into
devices like this implant here,
which is again about the size
of a coin.
It's made of a very special
polymer that's different than
the kinds that are used in
contact lenses,
in that it slowly dissolves.
If I implant this coin made of
this kind of material into the
body it will slowly dissolve.
If I implant it into the skin
and then I go back and I look
several months later,
the implant itself is totally
disappeared.
Of course you can't do this
without any--with just any kind
of material.
It has to be a very special
material that's both
biocompatible,
that your body doesn't respond
to,
and that dissolves down to
molecules that are not toxic.
It's not so easy to design
these things,
but there are some materials
that are available now.
What we did in this experiment
was showed that you could load
these polymers with chemotherapy
drugs.
These are just three different
chemotherapy drugs.
You could load them in such a
way that if you put this
material into water that
chemotherapy drugs would be
slowly released.
That's what's shown here.
This is with the drug BCNU,
it's a drug that's commonly
used to treat--or at least it
was in the 1990s,
commonly used to treat brain
cancer.
It's released over a period of
seven days;
90% of the drug is released and
then the last 10% comes out over
a period of several months.
If we look longer than that,
all the drug is gone now and
then the polymer itself starts
to dissolve.
By three months later,
or four months later,
the whole device has
disappeared.
It disappears in an orderly
fashion.
In fact, we engineered it to
work just this way,
such that most of the drug
would be released rapidly over a
period of a week,
10% of the drug would be
released more slowly over a
period of several months,
and then the device itself
would be completely gone in a
period of six months or so.
What would you use this for?
Well, this was designed as a
device that you would give to
neurosurgeons so that they could
improve therapy of brain tumors.
You probably know that tumors
of the brain are among the most
difficult to treat.
If you get a tumor in the
central nervous system they have
very poor prognosis or life
expectancy.
People that get aggressive
brain tumors die within a very
short time after it's diagnosed,
unfortunately.
That situation hasn't changed
much over the last 100 years.
One of the reasons is what we
mentioned earlier,
that the brain is protected
from chemical entry by the blood
brain barrier.
Capillaries in your brain don't
allow molecules to move across
them.
There's good reasons for that,
so that your brain chemistry
can remain constant throughout
the day.
Because of that blood brain
barrier, if you give drugs the
normal way by taking pills or
injections,
you get high doses everywhere
else but not very much gets into
the brain.
We thought that when they
do neurosurgery to remove a
tumor, which is commonly done,
the brain is exposed.
The surgeon has an opportunity,
then, to do something
extraordinary.
That is to, after the surgery,
they remove the tumor then they
could place these wafers inside
the surgical resection cavity.
Where the tumor used to be,
you place these coins that are
made of this degradable polymer
that released these drugs very
slowly.
The patient leaves the
operating room with most of
their tumor gone,
and in addition,
these drug delivery systems
which are releasing drugs slowly
to kill any tumor cells that
remain in the vicinity of the
surgical site.
This is a different strategy
for drug delivery.
It's a very specialized
strategy for delivering drugs.
It's one that takes advantage
of the fact that you're having a
medical procedure already.
Can we design something that's
going to make that procedure
even more effective?
This was approved by the FDA;
it's now the standard of care
for treating brain tumors
at--most countries in the world.
How could you make this
more--how could you make this
kind of technology,
or this kind of engineering,
more accessible?
Like here was an example,
actually several examples,
of very specialized
applications of this different
form of drug delivery.
Well, one way you could do it
is by shrinking these devices
down, so that they're so small
they could be introduced through
a needle.
Those wafers I showed you
before could be used by surgeons
because they--the tissue is
exposed and you could implant
things in.
That's not the case for many
other indications;
surgery isn't done in every
medical situation.
If you could put a needle into
the body and introduce these
delivery systems through
needles,
then maybe that would make it
better for other forms of
disease.
These are micro-particles,
they're made of the same kinds
of degradable polymers but
they're very tiny particles now.
In section this afternoon we'll
talk about how you make these
kinds of particles,
and you'll actually be able to
make some.
These particular ones are made
of the same kind of polymer that
slowly degrades,
but they're very small,
they're a micron or so in
diameter.
They're much,
much smaller than a needle and
they can be injected through a
needle.
You just imagine suspending
these particles which look like
dust in water,
and then injecting them through
a needle.
They also have the property
that you can put drugs in them
at fairly high concentration and
the drugs are released slowly
over time.
If I put a needle into a tissue
and introduce these particles,
the particles will sit there at
the tissue site and they'll
release the drug molecules for a
long period time just like the
implants do.
Just to show that this
works and how tiny you might be
able to make the particles and
how locally you might be able to
deliver them,
we made some particles like
this and we injected them into
the eye of an animal that had
retinal disease.
The animal had a disease of the
retina such that would cause
blindness.
Ordinarily there are many drugs
that are known to prevent this
kind of blindness,
but they have short half-lives.
If I inject the drug directly
into the eye it disappears
within a day.
So, here's a drug that works,
here's a condition that it
works in.
It's a condition that causes a
very serious medical problem,
blindness but in order to use
the drug you have to get an
injection in the eye everyday.
That's the only way to get
concentrations high enough for
it to be effective.
If you put it into the
particles that I showed you
before, you put the same drug
into the particles,
you inject the particles into
the eye, the particles stay
there in the eye.
They stay there for a long
time, and drug concentration now
lasts for 30 days instead of one
day.
This takes what would be an
unthinkable therapy,
difficult to think even if
blind--if you want to avoid
blindness,
difficult to think about
getting an injection in your eye
once a day for the rest of the
time you want to remain
eyesight,
but you might think about it
once a month if it meant the
difference between being able to
see and not being able to see.
If we could make the particles
better, such that they worked
for three months,
that makes it even more
possible.
If they work for a year--then
once a year, and you can see
that's a therapy that would be
acceptable to most people.
It's an example of an approach
but it also shows the
constraints of the approach.
So far we can do a month;
we'd like to be able to do
longer.
As we do longer this will
become a more--a therapy that's
more likely to be adopted into
clinical practice.
You can imagine that making
it longer requires better
engineering of these particles.
It's hard to make particles
that are really small but hold
onto drugs for a long time.
That's a hard thing to make
particles that are really small
but hold onto drugs for a long
time.
What we've gotten good at so
far is making particles that are
really, really small.
These are the--these are sort
of the state-of-the-art.
These are particles that are
made of a degradable polymer.
They're only 150 nanometers in
size, so now much smaller than a
micron even;
these are the size of a virus.
We were talking about
smallpox virus before,
a naturally occurring pathogen.
These are synthetic polymers
made totally in the laboratory
that are the same size as a
virus and they're made of a
polymer that's well known to be
safe and they also contain drug.
These particular particles were
made by a graduate student who
worked with named Amarilys
Sanchez,
and Amarilys was able to put
20% by weight of a chemotherapy
drug inside these very tiny
particles,
particles the size of a virus.
Even though the particles are
very tiny the drug comes out
relatively slowly over a period
of about a week.
Now, why make particles so
small?
Well, it turns out that these
particles are so small that they
can actually enter cells.
Like viruses they can infect
cells, only they don't infect in
the same way that a virus does
because they're totally
synthetic.
They don't reproduce,
they just sit inside the cells
and they release chemotherapy
drugs, in this case.
Well, that's--makes
possible a totally different
strategy for treating cancer.
One of the problems with
treating cancer is that cancer
drugs have to get deep inside
the cell in order to work.
Most of them work by inhibiting
cell division and most of the
targets for inhibiting cell
division are not just within
cells,
they're within the nucleus
inside the cell.
The approach for chemotherapy
is to deliver these toxic drugs
all over the body and hope that
they get into tumor cells.
Hope that they get into tumor
cells at high enough
concentrations that they can
reach these targets deep in the
nucleus.
What is possible,
we think, with this approach is
that you can design not just
long release of drugs,
but you can design particles
that will specifically recognize
tumor cells in the same way that
viruses recognize tumor cells or
specific cells that will enter
only certain cells,
and that they'll release their
drugs only when they've entered
the correct cell.
That would be potentially a
much safer, more effective form
of chemotherapy.
I've taken,
in this lecture,
and covered a lot of material,
but the important things I hope
are to--which I've emphasized,
I hoped, are to think about
ordinary forms or common forms
of drug administration like
pills and injections,
and understand a little bit
about how those forms of
administration lead to
concentration changes within the
body as a function of time,
and how those forms are limited
in some ways.
Now, even with those
limitations, obviously medical
therapy has advanced
tremendously because of the
availability of drugs.
Antibiotics have changed our
lifespan.
People don't die of infectious
diseases because of vaccines and
because there are antibiotics
that you can take,
sometimes orally.
We all have taken them.
You've taken antibiotics and
you got better,
so drug therapy has been an
incredible advance.
The second part I want you
to think about is how sort of
engineering of materials,
in the case I've described
here, could allow you to think
about making systems for drug
delivery that are even better.
That can take existing drugs
and expose them to the body in
different ways such they're
safer and more effective at
treating certain kinds of
diseases.
We'll meet at section this
afternoon;
any questions?
Great, see you this
afternoon.